philosophe de l'image et directeur
d'imagination
les gens qui la plupart des jeunes qui
aujourd'hui font des films je parle pas
de vidéo d'image virtuel tout le bazar
on sort de plus en plus au point oui il
prétendent ils
prétendent ils essayent
de nous montrer des choses qui n'ont pas
vu non seulement qui n'ont pas appris le
temps de regarder mais qui n'ont pas vu
c'est-à-dire que tout ça c'est la
délégation à la machine nous vivons
toute façon dans un monde de délégation
si maintenant on délègue à la machine ce
qu'on voit et bien
est-ce que vous croyez que c'est pas
déjà en train d'être fait
oui puisque l'effet m'a existent en
question on voit très bien qu'il y a
rien sur l'écran puisqu’il vous montre
des choses qui n'ont pas vu ni regarder
pour voir il faut regarder il faut
regarder des siècles il faut regarder la
culture c'est comme la géologie ça c'est
des siècles des siècles des millénaires
il y a un proverbe il y a un proverbe
irlandais qui est en tête du du journal
de irlandais de Heinrich bold y a de
nombreuses années en allemand c'est
alscott dead show
dafone lorsque Dieu a fait le temps il
en a fait il en a fait assez bon alors
si on oublie ça il y a qu'à tirer
l'échelle parce que les images nous
empêchent pas de regarder
le mot virtuel est un mot très ancien il
vient du latin qui veut dire l'homme et
on parle d'image on parle de numérique
et en plus ancien que ça monsieur a
parlé de géologie le mot image se trouve
à deux endroits de la Bible tout à fait
au début tout à fait à la fin l'homme
est de Dieu dit la Bible et à la fin
aussi on trouve le mot image c'est Jésus
qui est l'image du père vous voyez c'est
de la mot très ancien le nombre c'est
Pythagore qui a inventé le premier
philosophie du nombre c'était il y a 28
siècles et quand au virtuel un mot très
ancien aussi c'est le mot qui s'oppose
le mieux au réel qui est la chose même
et il s'oppose à la chose comme l'homme
se pose à la chose donc on a affaire des
concepts très anciens et moi ce que
j'aimerais prendre comme point d'attaque
c'est ne pas parler des machines on va
parler
[Musique]
grec et images c'est idées non il y a
deux choses
difficiles de traduire le texte de Shaun
bar précisément
l'étymologie d'image dans la Bible c'est
idée bon je voulais dire simplement une
chose il se trouve que j'ai un peu il y
a deux mots dans dans le grec il y a
icône et idole et quand vous parlez
d'idées vous parlez d'idole précisément
dans le dans le dans le dans le grec de
icône il y a pas l'idée d'idole il y a
l'idée d'icône et quand vous dites idée
vous êtes dans le dans l'idole
précisément alors quand je dis que Dieu
est Dieu a fait l'homme à son image on
parle d'icône qui est tout à fait
différent et dans le virtuel aujourd'hui
on a précisément ce double ce double
ambiguïté
iconidole dans le virtuel dans le
virtuel il y a un aspect idolique
idolâtre il y a un aspect iconique
iconolât et qui qui peut à mon avis et
justifier la complexité du débat
simplifions pas s'il vous plaît essayons
d'être un tout petit peu plus nuancé
parce que il y a pas la grande
catastrophe
par rapport à ces images il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui et le problème de l'image
c'est pas le problème de la technologie
ça c'est vraiment banal maintenant les
gamins de 5 ans manipulent c'est c'est
technologies comme n'importe quoi mais
non le problème n'est pas celui de la
technologie qui est banalisé c'est le
problème tout simplement de l'homme
aujourd'hui quand une technologie comme
l'image se dégage ça change quoi ça
change notre regard sur nous-même de
même que la photographie de même que la
peinture a changé notre vision de
nous-même aujourd'hui le virtuel ça
change quelque chose de très profond
mais qui est pas de l'ordre
technologique que d'ordre
essentiellement métaphysique ça change
notre propre regard sur nous-mêmes parce
que plus grave alors c'est encore plus
grave mais dans un bon sens dans un sens
lourd dans un sens le mot grave un beau
sens c'est le sens de la de la lourdeur
qui s'enfonce dans dans le réel puisque
vous parliez allemand il y a de guerre
qui a parlé de ces penseurs superficiels
qui font qu'avancer il parlaient les
opposés à ces penseurs profonds qui sont
bourbent qui s'enfoncent qui sont lourds
comme justement
vous êtes mal tombé avec moi parce que
ça n'est pas mon homme
tout de suite
non mais à cause de sa collaboration
avec les nazis j'imagine pas seulement
bon qu'est-ce que ça va nous apporter
comme supplément d'âme le virtuel alors
dans l'avenir et dans ce siècle
Christophe la distance l'époque la
phénoménologie
j'étais en train de parler de
d'abstraction il semble il semble que
pour certains observateurs comme le roi
Gourin le progrès de la civilisation
viens de la capacité à l'absorption
en train de dire que le progression
de l'abstraction et cette abstraction
aujourd'hui c'est la capacité à se
distancer et se mettre hors de soi-même
et vous vous mettez mort de vous-même
pour avoir plus de conscience que
vous-même et donc celle de dire c'est
que aujourd'hui avec le virage avec le
virtuel nous avons une capacité
d'abstraction supplémentaire qui va nous
faire faire progresser en au moins
c'est le plus grand menson de l'humanité
le seul progrès actuellement ce serait
le saut du tigre dans le passé faire la
révolution c'est remettre en place des
choses très anciennes mais oubliez
celui-là il était pas subversif il
s'appelait Peggy c'était un bon français
alors
bon
courrez à la Bible vous courez à la
Bible elle achète Yves pécore sans flash
si bien qu'à la fin elle creva mais vous
serez mort mais c'est les jeunes que
vous faites crever les générations
futures que vous programmez
il y a jamais une seule époque dans
l'histoire de l'humanité ou les
générations étaient programmées pour
trois ou quatre générations en avant ça
c'est jamais vu et c'est ça la barbarie
c'est au-delà de la barbarie
du plaisir à faire des images ce qui les
fabrique ce qu'il est créé
à pouvoir parler de ce plaisir voilà et
ça c'est extrêmement humain c'est c'est
très ancien c'est dans nos gènes dans
nos plaisirs dans nos envies
au début de ces histoires romaines vous
arriverez il parle de gens qui ce qu'il
appelle à gentesse une rébus puisque
vous vouliez parler là-dedans c'est les
agents dans les affaires dans Port-Louis
c'était au début de la catastrophe on en
est pas loin j'espère parce que plutôt
ça vaut mieux savoir comme disait
marguera elle disait que le monde Aya sa
perte ça je ne partage pas mais je dis
que ce monde là ah il y a sa perte est
le plus tôt possible et les Indiens
c'est une rébus et ben c'est des gens
comme vous je porte assez de c'étaient
de la police vous êtes un agent
publicitaire
je connais pas monsieur stroobs vraiment
incroyable
les images allez nous donner un
supplément d'âme pourquoi et de quelle
façon et de quelle manière
ecoutez moi je connais un prophète qui
disait que Nini valait disparaître sous
les eaux et puis finalement il se plaint
que Ninive n'est pas disparu sous les
eaux je crois pas au grand prophète du
grand soir je crois pas cette espèce de
déversement de hargne de Bill et de
haine je crois que le monde va grosso
modo vers quelque chose qui s'appelle
l'avenir moi je pense que moi écoutez
monsieur strobe
que vous êtes extrêmement puissant la
planète
monsieur strob vous ne me ferez trois
enfants monsieur strobe vous êtes
haineux et moi je peux vous dire que moi
l'avenir de l'aide et je pense que le
grand message que j'ai envie de donner à
l'avenir c'est un message d'amour parce
que moi j'ai trois enfants et ils vont
vivre cela et vous vous avez simplement
un tombereau de haine et d'injures à
déverser je vous le connaissez pas vous
m'avez agressé vous avez même pas qui je
suis et vous me traitez la joie de la
CIA mais c'est incroyable vous êtes
haineux et ceci est absolument
insupportable
et vraiment je comprends pas que vous
soyez à ce point tombereau comme ça de
haine noir et vous parlez allemand et
vous parlez allemand avec une espèce de
haine qui est incroyable et vraiment je
suis hors de moi parce que c'est ça ceci
non je reste simplement dire une chose
une seule chose je crois que la vie est
compliquée le monde est complexe il se
globalise et bien on va pourtant vers
des choses qui sont vers du plus de
quelle manière et pourquoi alors je vais
vous répondre simplement je crois que
les humains attendez laissez-le je suis
d'accord
Jean-Marie le seul salut ça serait moins
un peu moins bien alors on écoute le
seul chose la seule chose que je
voudrais dire de simple c'est que le
monde se complique et les images
virtuelles nous permettent de nous tirer
hors de cette complexité pour au moins
la rejeter ça nous permet d'aller vers
une sorte d'abstraction au sens latin on
se retire hors du monde on sort du monde
parce que nous ne sommes pas du monde
nous sommes dans le monde et le fait
d'avoir du virtuel le virtuel nous
permet de sortir hors du monde ce qui
était un geste philosophique
ontologique et quand vous parlez de
technologie vous pouvez expliquer un peu
plus précisément écoutez nous sommes
dans le monde à partir du moment où nous
naissons nous sommes dans le monde des
images qui vont nous environner vont
nous extraire du monde est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est bien il y a trop de
gens qui se croient tisser du même tissu
que le monde alors que je pense que nous
sommes des êtres spirituels je pense que
nous sommes des êtres qui sont a priori
n'ont pas du monde mais que nous sommes
dans le monde et que la technologie du
virtuelle est une manière de
démocratiser cette l'intuition
fondamentale que nous sommes arrivés ici
par hasard mais que nous sommes
peut-être appelés en sortir et que le
virtuel d'une manière de me dire le réel
n'est que n'est que du réel c'est pas
grand chose Noël c'est c'est de la chose
c'est de la chose non c'est pas tout ce
qu'on a non c'est pas tout ce qu'on a
non ce n'est pas tout ce qu'on a non ce
n'est pas facile qu'on a il y a beaucoup
de choses dans la dans le monde
Shakespeare Shakespeare jazz il y a
beaucoup de choses dans le monde qui ne
sont pas dans votre philosophie alors
vous êtes
en ligne le berceau des enfants le
berceau des enfants de la terre
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est la terre oh
mais ça c'est la philosophie maintenant
pour le coup c'est vraiment tisme avec
tous en danger que ça peut avoir
exactement
je suis non je suis contre l'humanitisme
et contre cet aspect là de la pensée
imaginons on a montré un aveugle qui
était équipé d'un d'un casque stéréo qui
était relié par satellite il pouvait se
promener dans le monde réel en étant
connecté par satellite à une carte qu'il
portait sur son ordinateur c'est bien
qu'il pouvait se promener dans le monde
réel en étant guidé par les sons et donc
il existe dans un espèce de serre sonore
virtuel correspondant au réel donc
l'opposition réelle virtuelle est
vraiment Fantine et simpliste
aujourd'hui le virtuel est dans quelque
sorte une sorte d'ange au-dessus du réel
qui vient aider le réel et c'est pas en
train c'est pas important
c'est un peu aussi ce qui s'est passé
pendant la guerre du Golfe c'est aussi
possible
vous chantez bien Jean-Marie je
comprends que vous mettiez en scène des
opéras dans le fait que Gobel ça gagne
la guerre c'est pire que les nazisme
comme chronique d'un homme magdalada
je vous me dissolu mais un point vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point je suis déçu
aujourd'hui à vous parce qu'il y a dans
la musique de barre c'est quelques
siècles de paysanneries
[Musique]